il
asnières octobre pour la première fois
depuis six ans les enfants vont
apprendre à lire sans redouter le bruit
des sirènes ou le fracas des bombes
ils font que ce petit monde grandissent
et s'instruisent en fait
[Musique]
non
spectacle toujours le même et toujours
nouveau le premier jour c'est
merveilleux comme on est sage mais
maxime les plus sévères sont avalés avec
le sourire
[Musique]
entrée de paix mais encore rentré de
crise leur trouvera-t-on des livres des
crayons et cahiers et des souliers
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
g
avec le 1er octobre écoliers collégiens
et lycéens ont pris ou repris le chemin
de l'école au milieu d'un optimisme plus
ou moins mitigés et jusqu'au dernier
moment certains ont pu encore craindre
ou espérer qu'on ne les prendrait pas
faute de place
car dans ce domaine comme dans l'autre
la crise du logement sévit
il s'agit de cas 17 millions d'élèves le
sixième de la population française va à
l'école mais tout le monde sera acceptée
en se serrant un peu il est bon à côté
des anciens bâtiments et en attendant
que les nouveaux soit achevé on a ouvert
des écoles provisoire c'est ainsi que
dans paris plusieurs écoles ou lycées
ont maintenant une ou plusieurs annexes
plus on a mis en place des classes
préfabriquées malgré l'accroissement
considérable des effectifs tous les
enfants iront à l'école et souhaitons
que les solutions provisoires ne soit
que provisoire
[Musique]
[Rires]
l'aube n'aurait pas dû avoir ce matin là
la même d'analyser que les autres matin
il est vrai que le grand événement qui
devait se produire sur le territoire des
treize académies de la zone à échappa
aux populations laborieuses
il concernait pourtant près du quart des
habitants
la première vague des 12 millions de
français d'âge scolaire allait prendre
le chemin de l'école un chemin oublié
depuis de longs mois
pas de problème de logement cependant
cette année malgré trois cent soixante
dix mille élèves de plus le retard en
bâtiment a été rattrapé
reste le cas des enfants à ce point pour
la première fois à la prolongation de la
scolarité de 14 à 16 ans
le problème est nouveau et il faudra
occuper ses 130 mille élèves prolongée
et puis il y à lait maternel
[Musique]
on a tout dit sur le premier jour de
classe
le premier contact avec l'école l'entrée
dans la condition écolière c'est la
première vraie mutation dans la vie d'un
enfant
le deuxième ce bras et c'est pourquoi la
scène se joue parfois comme un petit
drame en trois actes
au lever de rideau de 8h30
[Musique]
oui
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
le nombre d'enfants de 3 à 5 ans ne
cesse d'augmenter
cette année il va falloir faire front à
la vague de 2 millions de petits
écoliers et trouver le moyen de les
faire sourire il y a beaucoup de mères
sans doute ce jour là qu'ils se sont
sentis toutacoo orpheline d'enfants
on remarque est engagé
[Musique]
le savoir et de beaucoup la portion la
plus considérable du bonheur sophocle
[Musique]
ah oui
[Applaudissements]
à
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
m
et
[Musique]
à
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
allez
samedi
[Musique]
là
une grande ville mais dans les petits
m
[Musique]
les flots
il
dans nord bb elle est valide tenir en
trois sets oublier un piqué une crise de
9% et coûtant
[Musique]
alors moi je me suis et j'ai été des
journées
j'avais pas très stressant parce que
j'étais très ému de ma nouvelle
maîtresse j'avais peur je veux pas
laquelle peut jaillir à thouars vous
avez peur et le fils tente d'être revenu
à l'école alors vous n'étiez pas
contente en vacances à bon travail très
gentil je trouve
et plus elle très jolie aussi si elle
est sévère jusque là encore parce que
pour le moment elle est très gentil je
trouve même
et aujourd'hui pour la rentrée j'ai
l'impression que vous êtes un peu en
avance non parce qu'elle veut venir en
avance
ça rajeunit ça donne l'impression du spa
connais pas encore le
complètement en dehors de la vie active
il est là et les accompagner et pourquoi
vous accompagne et vous assure que pour
nourrir ce serait de l'animation des
clients surtout oui ça fait de
l'animation la pagaille il est gauche
pour taper dans les vitrines
et puis ce joli coffret cadeau oui ça
vous fait plaisir de revoir alors je
suis sûr que comme moi comme de très
nombreux parents vous avez rêvé un jour
d'être petit oiseau est de voir comment
votre fille votre garçon a vécu sa
première matinée de classe bien pire
champetier jacques aubertin ont été pour
vous ces petits oiseaux n'ont pas voulu
faire de sentimentalisme leur diagnostic
vous le verrez et simplement clinique
mais il est fascinant
[Musique]
van leeuwen
[Applaudissements]
malgré les apparences l'intégration à la
classe va se faire très vite
[Musique]
la maîtresse cherche à établir un
premier contact symbolique les moins
timides accepte de l'engagement mais les
réticences sont nombreuses sans cri sans
larmes sept enfants s'est tout de suite
en fermé sur lui-même il faudra sans
doute plusieurs jours pour l'apprivoiser
[Musique]
l'attrait de la nouveauté commence à
faire son effet
[Musique]
plus à l'aise les petits curieux partent
à la découverte de la classe ils
prennent possession des lieux
[Musique]
l'unique et du groupe se forme
spontanément autour des pinceaux et des
couleurs chacun apporte sa contribution
à l'oeuvre collective la classe se
soudent elle-même sans l'aide de la
maîtresse c'est gribouillis sont à
l'image de la classe qui se cherchent et
se trouve
[Musique]
la communication s'établit par gestes
cris bruit ou regard mais deux heures a
fait la rentrée aucune parole n'a été
échangée
[Musique]
on sent que les dernières défenses sont
sur le point de tomber pendant la
récréation les solitaires et les timides
gravitent autour de la maîtresse
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ces échanges de coups sont aussi une
façon de se mesurer et de se connaître
[Musique]
oui
après la récréation une nouvelle étape
est franchie on se parle leurs petits
groupes le dialogue s'instaure autour
des futurs leaders de la classe juste
avant l'arrivée des mamans l'intimité du
groupe et créer la nouvelle classe est
né
[Musique]
toujours à propos de la rentrée des
classes cette particularité en france le
taux de scolarisation en maternelle à de
rares exceptions près regarder les
chiffres tous les enfants de trois ans
100 % vont en classe en estime même que
30% sont scolarisés dès 2 ans de la vie
les experts l'enfant a tout à y gagner
mallory aoun ou diane richard un si gros
chagrin de dessin est finie charles sait
que sa maman d'en partir
quant au papa il cherche comment s'en
sortir
les jeux les brames c'est mieux quand
c'est pratique mais un papier s'équipent
ce plus vite
ils sont confiants nous avons fait
beaucoup de bien d'être un petit peu
avec d'autres enfants pour des activités
à apprendre apprendre la vie en
collectivité je pense que c'est une
bonne base pour démarrer dans la vie
un privilège français 27 % des enfants
sont scolarisés dès 2 ans la
quasi-totalité un an plus tard un
nouveau monde pour apprendre avec et au
milieu des autres
dès le plus jeune âge tous les moyens
sont bons le jeu on amène les enfants à
communiquer à s'exprimer pia a progressé
dans tous les domaines ya atmosphère
plus studieuse chez les grands
aujourd'hui un terreau sur les vacances
encore maîtrisé l'oral puis les syllabes
pour aller progressivement vers
l'écriture
en attendant on travaille la motricité
on s'éveille au beauf
les enseignants eux observent leur
mission s'est aussi dit fier d'éventuels
problèmes scolaires familiaux ou même de
santé l'aïe un travail plus spécifique
on revoit la psychologue pour voir où on
en est voire si besoin d'un suivi à
l'extérieur d'orthophonie sous de
psychomotricienne ou ou plus qu'en fera
des difficultés l'égalité des chances se
joue donc dès la maternelle et qui sont
un rêve très simple
et comment tu est grande
il
[Musique]